Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
excel miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube cá Excel bài thứ
10 định dạng theo trước khi bắt đầu vào
bài số 10 thì mình cùng giải bài tập hôm
trước là bài số 9 nhá để bạn tích vào
đây các bạn mở cái câu hỏi lên ok bài số
9 mình sẽ có năm cái câu hỏi là gì ạ câu
hỏi thứ nhất mình sẽ chích xuất nhà phân
phối Viettel ở đây là yêu cầu là làm
theo cùng xít và các xít thì mình sẽ làm
ở khát ít nhá Còn cùng ship thì dễ hơn
thì họ sẽ làm ở cùng chích Thôi bây giờ
ví dụ mình tạo một cái sĩ khác là xin
lỗi là 92 đi đấy thịt câu hỏi thứ nhất
là diện tích xuất nhà phân phối Viettel
đúng không thì các bạn phải copy cái
phần tiêu đề thì đầu tiên mình sẽ tạo
một cái vùng điều kiện nhất đầu tiên ở
nhà phân phối Đúng không các bạn sẽ copy
cái nhà phân phối này này bạn sẽ vứt vào
đây Các bạn nhớ nhất phải gặp đây ví dụ
tiếp đây các bạn có thể biết xem cái 92
cũng được nhá thì hay là mình viết cho
xin hai đi lại
Em sắp viết ở đây cho nó dễ này tại nhà
phân phối qua tích tụ ở đây mình sẽ còn
lại đây nhá nhà phân phối ở đây là gì ạ
Đây là Viettel đúng không Đây Yêu cầu là
nhà phân phối Viettel đầu tiên nào có
một điều kiện để chết đã nhắc thì ví dụ
mình làm ở cái sheet Hay là mình chiết
xuất ra đi nhé lại các bạn sẽ vào cái
Hai chiếc này rồi còn vào thẻ data Các
bạn chọn SV đấy thì đầu tiên là cái list
lên nhắc có sẽ tích vào cái ô lít lên
các bạn xanh ấy cần ship một này các bạn
Bôi đen toàn bộ cái phần tiêu đề đây các
bạn giữa canxi và mũi xuống để như vậy
mình sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ liệu
của mình rồi đúng không các bạn tích vào
đây là cái vùng điều kiện thì ngay khi
các bạn tích vào cái vùng điều kiện thì
nó lại quay về cái xích ban đầu là thi
thứ hai là lúc đấy mình tạo với Advance
filter này Bây giờ mình sẽ xa cái sheet1
để mình lấy điều kiện nhé các bạn
em kéo lên đây thể gọi sẽ Bôi đen cái
phần điều kiện ở nhà phân phối và
Viettel ở đây để họ sẽ tích vào cái diện
copy to another location Tức là mình sẽ
chết Sắp tới đâu đấy nhá mình sẽ tích
vào cái ô ô copy tu này các bạn tiếp
theo tiếp theo là các bạn chọn ôm mình
cần chiết xuất Ví dụ mình chọn cái ô mê
hay là đi phải gọi sẽ thích ok thì như
vậy là dị toàn bộ dữ liệu mà nhà phân
phối Viettel đã được ra đây bác ạ tích
vào đây này các bạn chọn cái filter đấy
mình sẽ tích vào đây còn thấy chưa đây
chỉ có nhà phân phối Viettel không rất
là hai ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa đi nhá mình
sẽ xanh ấy câu hỏi thứ hai là chích suốt
nhà phân phối Viettel và VNPT thì rất
đơn giản thôi các bạn ấy gọi VNPT ở đây
đấy thì như vậy cái flvto nó sẽ lọc hai
cái điều kiện này cứ Viettel hoặc là
VNPT thì nó sẽ lấy đúng không các bạn
xanh cái sĩ thai thì còn chú nhắc ạ muốn
chiết xuất sang đâu vậy thì các bạn phải
làm vào cái sim đấy đúng không Ví dụ
mình muốn chiếc rất ít hay thì các bạn
phải làm ở cái thai này
Ở đây các bạn sẽ vào với hai nhá Rồi sau
đó Gọi vào tuyển data Các bạn chọn vậy
em văn ở đâu đấy thì đầu tiên là cái
list lên này cậu xích ở đây các bạn xanh
cái ship 1 đầu tiên bạn sẽ Bôi đen cái
phần tiêu đề này này Các giữ cần cho
ship mũi tên xuống tiếp theo là bạn thân
tích vào cái vùng điều kiện ở đây để các
bạn lại quay lại Cắt xít Một để mình lấy
điều kiện đúng không ạ kéo lên đây tivi
cái điều kiện của mình là mình đang ở
ship một mà còn nếu như các điều kiện
các bạn để ship hay thì đỡ phải sang đây
thì trong trường hợp mình anh để điều
kiện ở Cái sim này có thể tích theo có
diện tích và cái copy to another
location này các bạn phân tích và cái ô
ô capitu Sau đó các bạn diện tích và cái
ô mà các bạn còn cần quá tôi tới nhau Ví
dụ như copy vào cái ô A1 lại đi đấy Các
sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy Ở đây có nhà phân
phối Viettel và VNPT lại Ví dụ mình
filter đi lấy gọn thấy chứ Đây có
Viettel và VNPT Thôi nhá lại nó sẽ không
lấy FPT Hoặc là các nhà phân phối khác
bây giờ à
ở đây mình sẽ làm một cái câu thứ ba câu
thứ ba là gì chích suốt của Viettel và
sản phẩm 01 thì ở đây mình có hai điều
kiện đồng thời đúng không của Viettel và
các sản phẩm không một bên mình sẽ xóa
cái VNPT phải đi thì có bạn lại copy cái
điều kiện là sản phẩm ở đây các bạn copy
đề này các bạn nhớ phải kết vào đây Đấy
sản phẩm không một lúc các bạn cũng copy
sản phẩm 01 các bạn nhấn phải kết vào
đây đây ở đây nó đang hành thế nào nó sẽ
xảy ra đồng thời còn nếu như các sản
phẩm không ổn định hòa các bạn để ở dưới
này chẳng hạn thế nhá thì nó là rẻ cứ
Viettel thì nó sẽ chết xuất hoặc là việc
cứ sản phẩm 01 thì nó sẽ chết suốt đấy
Còn nếu như các bạn để nó nhanh hàng này
thì là hai cái điều kiện này là đồng
thời bây giờ các bạn sẽ sang cái thai để
mình làm nhé Đấy mình sẽ vào cái SV này
đợi các bạn sẽ tích và cái olive lên các
bạn Sai cái sĩ một để các bạn làm như
vừa xong không đấy còn giữ cái chân xin
mũi tên xuống còn thích vào cái ô vùng
điều kiện ở đây các bạn lại quay lại
ship một để mình lấy đi
ừ ừ
à còn kéo lên đây vì sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng
điều kiện này các bạn sẽ tích và kiệt
copy to another location tpo copy to và
các bạn thích và cái ô mà các bạn thân
chiết xuất Ví dụ ở đây là C2 còn của Ok
Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra nhé Viettel
và chẳng 01 nha chọn tích vào đây các
bạn sẽ chọn cái filter đấy còn đấy chứ
chỉ có Viettel thôi còn tích vào đây để
chỉ có sản phẩm 01 thôi đấy khá là hay
rồi Đúng Bên mình sẽ xóa đi mình sẽ sang
câu hỏi thứ tư nhá trích xuất dữ liệu là
năm 2019 Cái này là rất là hai con phải
sử dụng thủ thuật này nhá Nó không đơn
giản đâu đấy nó cũng không phức tạp lắm
và nó cũng không đơn giản nếu như bạn
không biết là mẹ rồi còn được phải cậu
biết đi có ý nghĩa cả Cậu cũng được đầu
tiên là gì đây là trích xuất của năm
2019 đúng không còn sẽ lấy cái ngày này
nghe được phải coffee
khi lấy phải viết vào đây Các bạn cũng
biết thêm một kết cục nữa cũng là ngày
cho mình đấy con thấy như vậy là hai cái
điều kiện ngày ở đây nhá Thì cái ngày
này các bạn sẽ ghi là điện lớn hơn vì là
gì ạ Cái điều kiện của mình là trong năm
2019 đúng không Thì nó phải lớn hơn hoặc
bằng là ngày mùng 1 tháng 1 năm 2019 đợi
đấy Tiếp theo là cái ngày ngày ở đây là
ngày cuối cùng của 2019 thì các bạn xem
cái năm 2019 ngày cuối cùng nó là bao
nhiêu đấy như nó là 31 tháng 12 năm 2019
nhé đấy cậu phải ghi là diện nhỏ hơn
hoặc bằng hiện đầy tháng 12 các bạn ghi
Khánh chiếc nhé Đến ngày bao nhiêu ngày
31 năm bao nhiêu 2019 đấy thì như vậy Ở
đây cái ngày nó xuất hiện 2 lần thì nó
phải thỏa mãn cả hai điều kiện này Đấy
mình sẽ dùng cái thủ thuật này tức là nó
phải lớn hơn hoặc bằng cái ngày đầu tiên
của năm và nhỏ nộp bằng cái ngày cuối
cùng của năm đây là 2 cái tiêu đề là
ngày giống hệt nhau Bây giờ mình sẽ làm
các bạn nha con xanh ấy xin hai này các
bạn vào thẻ data các bạn sẽ chọn
Ừ đấy thì đầu tiên là cái nick luôn đúng
không các bạn sẽ tích của Leesin các bạn
xanh cái ship một thì đầu tiên vẫn là
cái vùng dữ liệu của mình thôi đoạn giữa
các tướng ship Nguyên xuống Sau đó bọn
tích và cái ô điều kiện ở đây các bạn
lại sang cái xịt một nhá Đây mình sẽ kéo
lên trên đấy Gọi sẽ Bôi đen trong cùng
điều kiện ở đây lấy điều kiện là gì từ
y12 đến j13 này nè đấy sau đó còn chọn
được copy tụ and location các bạn sẽ
tích và cái ô copy tui ở đây này đấy cậu
sẽ chọn bị ô mình cần copy tới ví dụ làm
B2 đây các bạn sẽ chọn ok đấy còn bây
giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra nhé mình sẽ xích đu
cái ngày tháng này lại các bạn sẽ chọn
cái filter này Bây giờ còn thích vào cái
filter của ngài đây nhá đấy Gọi thế cho
nó chỉ có năm 2019 thôi đấy Tư viện từ
cái tháng 1 đến tháng 12 luôn lại rất là
hai ạ Ở đây mình sẽ có 2 cách thủ thuật
cho các bạn nhé Nếu như mà cạn muốn cái
ngày nó thỏa mãn đồng thời của một cái
khoản ở đấy thì cái ngày ở đây sẽ xuất
hiện 2 lần tức là
chị của khác nhau để ngủ với cột là lớn
nó bằng vào một cái cột này nhỏ lọc bằng
lại mình sẽ lấy được cái khoảng thời
gian này Đây là cái thủ thuật khá là hay
đấy Ok bây giờ cái câu số 5 là trích
xuất dữ liệu đây là năm 2019 này của
Viettel và của miền bắc đúng không Thì
như vậy Cái ngày đây là không đổi rồi
Đúng là mình sẽ có hai ngày bây giờ mình
sẽ copy cái nhà phân phối nhập phải thế
Rất phải vào đây mình Tết và gì ạ và
miền Bắc Đúng không khu vực gọn copy cái
khu vực nhớ thì phải đây mình sẽ kết khu
vực đấy mình sẽ lấy 1 cái miền Bắc nhá
copy thì miền Bắc lại bạn nhảy và khu
vực đây là miền Bác đây nhà phân phối
Viettel Đúng không các bạn copy cái chữ
Viettel Đấy cho bạn đẩy ra nhà phân phối
đã đợi như vậy mình đã thiết lập xong
cái cùng điều kiện rồi nhá hai cái phần
này ở đây để đảm bảo là hiện năm 2019
này còn đây là nhà phân phối Viettel vào
đây là khu vực miền Bắc vậy mình sẽ xa
như sinh ra để mình làm vì xóa cái dữ
liệu cũ đi đợi Bây giờ con sẽ tích
ở đây cái còn biết lên nhá các bạn xanh
cái ship một các bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng
tiêu đề giữ cần cho ship những cái xuống
các bạn sẽ tích mà cái vùng điều kiện ở
đây mình lại sang cái ship một đây Có ạ
lên lên anh hùng điều kiện để họ sẽ Bôi
đen toàn bộ cái vùng điều kiện rồi đây
các bạn thích và cái copy tụ another
location hãy chọn sẽ tích và cái ô ô cap
tu ở đây và các bạn chọn cái ô mình cần
copy tới ví dụ là cái ô C4 này các bạn
muốn Ok Đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra nhé
để có diện tích vào đây mình nhé Vào
filter bây giờ mình sẽ xem cái phần ngày
trước đấy cảm thấy ngày đây nó chỉ có
năm 2019 thôi nó không có năm 2020 được
cái khu vực ở đây bạn xem mà đấy nó chỉ
có miền Bắc thôi đấy và cái nhà phân
phối ở đây nó cũng chỉ có Viettel tôi
đấy cảm thấy ông rất là hai ạ Bây giờ
nếu như mà các bạn bún cái doanh thu lo
trong một cái khoản ở đấy nhá Thì các
bạn sẽ điền hai câu doanh thu vào đây
Đấy một cái khoảng là dưới một cái là
vào một cái thận dư
ở trên đấy là cái cách mà mình muốn thêm
với điều kiện thì ok như vậy mình đã
xong đây câu hỏi cho cái bài tập lý 9
hôm trước nhé mình sẽ đóng lại Ok Bây
giờ mình sẽ vào bài hôm nay là bài số 10
là định dạng Xem toàn Mở cái bài số 10
lên thì các bạn chú ý nhá mình sẽ để cái
phần link tải file thực hành trong phần
mô tả phía dưới video thì tốt nhất là
các bạn tải về các bạn vừa theo dõi và
thực hành cùng mình nếu như bạn nào mà
không biết cách tải về thì các bạn sẽ
xem lại cái bài đầu tiên của các luật
bài Excel từ cơ bản đến nâng cao này nhá
Đấy thì trong cái bài đầu tiên đấy mình
đã hướng dẫn rất là chi tiết các cách
cách để các bạn tải về và các bạn giải
nén như thế nào đấy thì trong bài học
ngày hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
13 cái ví dụ về định dạng theo luôn hình
để các bạn vừa hiểu và vừa vào những cái
ví dụ thực tế luôn nhá đại thì đầu tiên
các bạn phải hiểu định dạng theo nghĩa
là gì thì định dạng tức là xe mình sẽ
thay đổi cái hình dạng thì thay đổi
có gì mình sẽ thay đổi phong này cỡ chứ
màu chữ hay là thì thay đổi cái kích
thước thì lấy đấy là cái định dạng thì
thông thường người ta hay là tô màu và
người ta sẽ tự động hoặc là đổi thấy màu
chữ hoặc là cựu Phong đẩy một số các
định dạng hay thay đổi nhất Bây giờ mình
sẽ vào cái phần đầu tiên là mình sẽ định
dạng hàng triệu hàng ngàn thì các bạn
Thúy Nga ở bên phải này mình đã có cái
hướng dẫn rất là chi tiết rồi lại để bạn
sẽ làm theo nhé Chỉ ở đây giả sử mình có
doanh thu bây giờ mình muốn biểu diễn
các doanh thu này dưới dạng hàng ngàn
hoặc hàng triệu thì mình làm như thế nào
thì tại sao mình lại biểu diễn ạ thì
thông thường các anh thu nó rất là lớn
nếu như mình để cái Việt Nam đồng làm
thì nó rất là tốn vào thứ ra nó cũng
không quá cần thiết bây giờ mình muốn
biểu diễn nó dưới dạng hàng ngàn hoặc
hàng triệu thì nó sẽ đơn giản hơn đúng
không đấy thì bước 1 là mình Chọn xem
cần quy đổi đây này Mình nhận hướng dẫn
rất là chi tiết rồi đúng không Mình sẽ
copy cái phần dữ liệu là chiếc này còn
nhớ thì phải copy đấy bạn Bôi đen Cái
vùng dữ liệu này về các bạn nhấn chuột
phải con phết rồi đấy ạ
Ừ như vậy Ở đây bản chất nó là ba dữ
liệu giống nhau rồi nhưng mà cái cột này
mình sẽ biểu diễn dưới dạng hàng ngàn đi
đây thì bạn sẽ Bôi đen nó này sau đó thì
các bạn sẽ nhấn chuột phải này các bạn
chọn format Cell để cậu sẽ vào với các
tầng thì ở đây mình sẽ xóa đi dưới cái
thai này gọi xóa đi và mình sẽ biết mới
nhá thì ở đây Các bạn chú nhà định dạng
hàng ngàn đây mình đã hướng dẫn rồi nhắc
bạn sẽ gõ là gì Con sẽ ghi là thang này
chấm 00.00 ở đây nghĩa là gì từ là mình
sẽ biểu diễn hai cái số sau cái số thập
phân đúng ạ đấy bạn phải nhá lại sau đó
giờ cạn mở ngoặc kép ra các bạn gõ chữ
ca đại ca là chữ như ngàn lại hoặc là
bạn rõ chính ngàn cũng được thì thông
thường người ta hay biểu diễn chữ k này
là hàng nào rồi đấy các bạn có thể thêm
cái dấu cách nhá cho nó cách cái chữ k
này ra nhìn nó đẹp hơn thôi các bạn thấy
chưa cạn Nhìn cái mẫu đây này Đấy thì
lúc đấy là gì lúc đấy là hơn 10 triệu
thì bây giờ mà biểu diễn dưới dạng hàng
ngàn thì nó chỉ còn là 10.940
ở đây gọi sẽ bấm ok thì bạn thấy chứ như
vậy cái dữ liệu của mình đã biểu diễn
với ca này là nhưng mà đây nó lại Thiện
nó lại không có cái dấu phẩy ngăn cách
giữa hàng nghìn ở đây rất là xấu đúng
không Bây giờ mình sẽ Bôi đen lại nhé
Mình làm lại nhé Đấy chị bây giờ để vào
format xe lại thì các bạn có thể bấm
phím tắt là căn trên ngồi cũng được nhé
đấy thì ở đây các bạn xét cho mình là gì
ạ Đây là chấm Không không không thì bạn
Thăng này phẩy các bạn sẽ ghi cho mình
là Trang tăng tăng đấy thì nghĩa là gì ạ
Nó sẽ ngăn cách các khách hàng ngàn với
nhau đấy Bây giờ gọi cho bấm ok đấy Bạn
thấy chứ lúc này nó ra làm gì 10,9 42.3
sáu này nó ngăn cách thì bạn nhìn nó dễ
hơn Đây là như vậy là tướng là 10.000
940k đấy Bây giờ mình sẽ biểu diễn hàng
triệu nhá Bây giờ các bạn lại Bôi đen
Cái vùng dữ liệu của hàng triệu này đấy
các bạn sẽ nhấn chuột phải các bạn vào
format Cell đấy hoặc là gì ạ Các bạn Bôi
đen các bạn tấn căn chung ngồi cũng được
nhé mình sẽ xóa cái này đi bây
ở đây là các bạn gõ đây này chỉ là chỉ
cần Thăng này chấm chị ạ Không không sau
đó còn cho mình là hai cái dấu phẩy cái
dấu phẩy đầu tiên ý nghĩa là gì nó biểu
diễn DK này cái dấu phẩy tiếp theo là
biểu diễn viên mê tức là biểu diễn hàng
triệu đấy sau đó còn mở ngoặc kép ra các
bạn bật như cách các bạn vào chữ m vào
đây các bạn đó ngoặc kép lại lại còn trú
nhà đặc biệt ở đây nó phải có hai cái
dấu phẩy thì hai cái dấu phẩy này cái
dấu phẩy đầu tiên là gì ạ Nó là biểu
diễn hàng ngàn và cái dấu phẩy tiếp theo
là biểu diễn thêm hàng triệu đấy Cái chữ
m này nó thêm vào tôi để nó sẽ làm tường
minh thêm lạc đây là triệu nhá mình cho
bấm ok đấy gọi thế chứ là 10.9 4 triệu
này rất là hay ạ hoặc là cái chữ m này
mình có thể thay thế bằng cái triệu nha
các bạn Bun lại các bạn ấn các chương 1
này Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa đi chữ m đấy đi
mình sẽ thay rằng chị triệu cũng được
đấy Tùy các bạn nhá Đấy còn thấy chứ như
vậy Ở đây là gì Cái gốc doanh thu ban
đầu là 10 triệu 940.000 Nếu mà biểu diễn
hàng ngàn thì đây Còn nếu biểu diễn hàng
triệu gì
anh nói rất là đẹp luôn tiếp theo là
liệu mình sắp chết mà giữ nguyên chế độ
rộng cột thì ở đây mình có thông tin và
sinh viên này đây là doanh thu theo kế
hoạch đây là doanh thu thực tế tại Ví dụ
như các bạn sinh viên là đi làm thêm rồi
hạn thế nhá hoặc là nhân viên đi đây là
nhân viên thì đúng không Ví dụ là nhân
viên kinh doanh người thanh khoản mà đây
là doanh thu kế hoạch từng ngày và thực
tế người ta đạt được từng này nhưng bây
giờ mình muốn chịu ô diện mình muốn cái
ô thực tế này cái cục này nó rộng bằng
cái doanh thu Kế hoạch đấy thì mình làm
như thế nào Bây giờ các bạn sẽ copy cái
phần doanh thu kế hoạch dài hạn thế nhá
hoặc các bạn có thể copy một cô bất kỳ
thôi cũng được còn nhớ thì phải các bạn
copy đấy các bạn sẽ nháy ăn phải vào một
cái ô bất kỳ của cái cục thực tế này các
bạn chọn paste special đấy và các bạn sẽ
chọn cho mình là cái care bít lại tức là
dịp mình chỉ copy cái độ rộng của tôi
cái khay lần quyết ở đây là gì ạ Nguyên
ở đây là độ rộng cột này lại bạn bấm ok
đấy thì như vậy cái cục thực tế này cái
độ rộng nó sẽ bằng cái độ rộng thì doanh
thu kế hoạch này sẽ rất là hai ạ thì nó
sẽ rộng ra nhìn nó
ở đây là cái cách mình copy để giữ người
Cái định dạng cột tức là độ rộng cột đấy
ok xanh đấy thứ ba là gì ở Mình chắc bạn
thêm số 0 vào Pho Mát nhá Để bây giờ là
giả sử đây là cái phần giá trị của mình
bây giờ mình muốn định dạng như thế này
thì mình làm như thế nào thì được tiên
Các bạn cứ copy dữ liệu ở đây còn nhớ
phải Coffee các bạn copy vào cái ô kết
quả thì mình biểu diễn nhé để cậu biết
rồi đây chứ bây giờ cái kết quả này mình
muốn biểu diễn dưới dạng 4 cái số không
à tức là diện nếu mà nó nhỏ hơn 4 số thì
mình sẽ thêm cái số không và để nó đủ 4
số đấy Đúng không các bạn xinh nhảy
chuột phải vào đây các bạn xem vào
format Cell nếu mà các bạn bấm tăng
trưởng một đi nhé đấy các bạn xem ở đây
mình sẽ vào cái phần các phẩm ở dưới cái
phần Than này các bạn sẽ gọi cho mình bố
mày số không Này cái bốn cái số không
này nghĩa là gì Nghĩa lần luôn luôn phải
có bốn số thể hiện trong Cái ô này tối
thiểu để gọi cho bấm ok đấy bạn đấy chứ
nếu mà ở đây là không Nếu như ở đây Lúc
nãy 123 thì nó sẽ tự Thêm số 0 vào ví dụ
Các bạn thấy
khi enter đấy thì nó sẽ chèn ba số 0 để
đủ 4 số ví dụ mà lớn hơn 4 số nha ví dụ
12345 nhạc thế nhất thì nó vẫn trả về là
12345 Thôi thì như vậy là điện nếu như
mà nhỏ hơn 4 số thì nó sẽ chèn số 0 vào
trước nó lại ví dụ 321 thế đấy thì nó sẽ
tiên số 0 và tiếp theo là gì mình muốn
định dạng như thế này thì thông thường
cái số điện thoại người ta hay định dạng
như thế này thì mình nhắn như thế nào cả
thích vào cái ô mà các bạn cần cố định
dạng như thế này nhá cái gọi tấn cá
trước một để còn lại vào các tầng thì ở
dưới cái phần Than này các bạn gọi cho
mình cho toàn võ diệu không không không
Này 4.0 có bằng cách ra không không
không Này các bạn cách ra còn thêm ba
cái số không nữa đấy thì như vậy nó cứ
10 số thì nó sẽ biểu diễn như thế này
bạn bấm ok đấy Cái số của mình rồi đây
ví dụ các bạn Nhập lại nha 1234567890
nữa các bạn em tự đấy thì nó lại biểu
diễn về cái dạng này cứ 4 số 3 số vào 3
số bây giờ ví dụ mình biểu diễn một số
lớn hơn 10 số đây tại 789 hạn chính các
bạn enter đấy
chỉ riêng 10 số đầu là biểu diễn như thế
còn số 12 thì ta sẽ thêm vào không đấy
tiếp theo là diện đây là biểu diễn dưới
dạng cái này thì các bạn cũng thích vào
đây đoạn và format Cell hoặc là căn
chung một nhá thì đây mình sẽ vào cái
phần các Tâm ở dưới này các bạn có đánh
như vậy tôi cậu đánh 4.0 này Các bạn bấm
dấu trừ này ba số không Này có đánh dấu
trừ và 3 số không đấy cũng rất là hay
thật đấy Bạn thấy chưa lại bây giờ gọn
sinh nhập vào đây bị 123456789 nhé Đấy
nó cũng được giữ như vậy bà nó sẽ thêm
với số 0 ở trên này đủ 10 số đấy tiếp
theo là ví dụ mình thêm cái chữ mã tỉnh
và diện ba cái chữ số sau mã tỉnh ở đây
ví dụ 21 ở đây thì nó sẽ biểu diễn ra
giữa mã tỉnh không 21 đấy thì mình làm
như thế nào nhá thì họ sẽ tích vào cái ô
kết quả Tức là cái ôm mình cần biểu diễn
à kahchan Một đấy Mình cho vào các em ở
dưới đây mình sẽ gọi bạn mở một tép ra
còn có chữ mã tỉnh với đây để bạn dịp
cách
khi đóng ngoặc kép lại sau đó toàn sẽ
đánh cho mình 3 cái số không cho đấy Bạn
thấy chứ còn nhìn trên các symbol đây
này Nó sẽ biểu diễn dưới dạng mã tỉnh
công 21 này bọn bằng Ok đại lớn nhưng
mình nhập nhập vào số một của đây nhá
thì nó sẽ hiện là mã tỉnh 001 này enter
để lại ví dụ là 124 Nhé thì nó sẽ ra làm
bạn tình online 4 nếu như 12345 thì nó
sẽ hiểu là mã tình 12345 thì thông
thường ở ở Việt Nam mình nhớ chỉ có là
63 tỉnh thành cho đúng không Thì ở đây
nó cứ Biểu diễn là ba số cho chắc chắn
rồi ví dụ là ba tư lại nhé đó sẽ là mã
tỉnh 034 xanh thứ tư là mình sẽ định
dạng ngày tháng đấy thì ở đây á Mình có
một số định dạng này ví dụ cái kết quả
đây ví dụ của mình là Rịa ngày 17 tháng
04 năm 2020 bây giờ mình muốn biểu diễn
các các loại định dạng này nhá Đấy ví dụ
mình muốn biểu diễn dưới dạng thì đây
này thứ này ngày tháng năm thì mình làm
như thế nào
ở đây là các cái kiểu format rồi mà mình
sẽ làm hướng về thôi Bây giờ mình rất
thích và cái ô gì ạ Ông ngày tháng nay
mình cần làm nhé để họ sẽ ấn căn chung
một cũng được trời thì sau đó bạn sẽ vào
cái phần cá tầm và các bạn có thể vào
cái bếp này luôn này nó sẽ có 1 số cái
tùy chọn phổ thông ví dụ đất này các bạn
thấy chưa Đấy con sẽ tích vào đây nó
giống hệt như cái yêu cầu đầu tiên cũng
được gạo theo bấm ok thì như vậy Ở đây
mình sẽ kéo rộng ra đấy nó sẽ có thứ này
ngày tháng mà năm tiếp theo mình sẽ biểu
diễn dưới dạng này mình muốn biểu diễn
dưới dạng tháng đến 5 đúng không đấy thì
bạn tích vào Cái ô này các bạn sẽ ấn cân
chân một này Đấy thì mình sẽ vào các tầm
nhé bạn Chúc tất cả mình sẽ vào các từ
Mỹ cho dễ cắt từ mình có thể biểu diễn
dưới dạng toàn bộ cái Trên này cũng được
nhá mình sẽ tùy chỉnh mà các bạn sẽ xóa
cái này đi Đấy bây giờ để biểu diễn dưới
dạng tháng đến năm nay còn gõ giống nhau
đi lên đây thì ở đây mình sẽ làm theo
cái cụ format này nha các bạn sẽ gõ ba
chữ m 3 chữ m là biểu diễn dưới dạng
tháng mà viết tắt đấy ạ
Ừ cái tháng tư nó viết tắt nó là apro
thì nó là apr đúng không Hãy gọn - các
bạn cảnh nha các bạn hai chữ y là biểu
diễn năng đấy hai mươi là năm 2020 có
bạn sẽ bóng mục kê đấy nó sẽ ra là tháng
tư năm 2020 bây giờ mình muốn biểu diễn
dưới dạng niệm ngày tháng năm như thế
này thì các bạn làm như thế nào là thích
rồi đây không các bạn thân trên một thôi
đấy các bạn làm giống hệt như thế này
nhá các bạn vào các tầng ở đây mình xóa
đi mình Nhi là diện hai chữ R đây này
trong gạch ngang ba chữ m gạch ngang 4
chữ y dài là năm đãi bạn sẽ có một cây
đấy thì tương tự như vậy con sẽ biểu
diễn khác cái trường còn lại như thế này
nhá Tiếp theo là cái phần số 5 là lựa
chọn trung tâm dữ liệu giả sử ở đây anh
em mình có doanh thu các quý bây giờ
mình có tất cả 4 Quý đúng không Mình
muốn cái ô doanh thu các quỹ này nó sẽ
căn đều của bốn ích quý này đúng không
thì thông thường nếu như mà các bạn mất
lại ạ Đấy thì gặp Model bốn cái và cậu
mất mạng nhưng mà
ở xã hội thì các bạn hạn chế là các bạn
bớt lại nhé Bởi vì khi còn muốn lại thì
các bạn dùng filter hay các bạn dùng các
cái kỹ năng khác thông thường là rất là
dễ bị sai đấy thì bây giờ để cái chữ
doanh thu các quỹ này nó nằm giữa bốn
cái ô này thì toàn là như thế nào đấy
thì đầu tiên bạn sẽ bôi 4 cái ôm này Đấy
sau đó gọn rẻ các bạn sẽ bấm cân một
hoặc các bạn nháy chuột phải các bạn
format Cell nhá Đấy con sẽ tích và cái
chữ reitman này thịt trong cái
horizontal này có thích nữa đây Các bạn
chọn cái Center across Selection Đức là
dẹp những cái ôm mình chọn đấy thì nó sẽ
được sắp xếp giữa vào cái ô mình chọn
các bạn bấm ok đấy thì vẫn thấy cái chữ
danh cho các quý này nó sẽ nằm giữa bốn
cái ô mình chọn nó đã mặc dù ý Cái ô này
nó nằm ở cái ô C4 này cái dữ liệu đó là
một C4 nhưng mà diện nó sẽ biểu diễn
diện nó sẽ nằm giữa bốn cái ô này lấy
đoạn theo khá là hay tiếp theo là diện
mình sẽ tạo dòng mới trong một ô thì
31 Ôn lại các bạn sẽ giữ ai mà các bạn ở
nhân tơ tại Ví dụ mình tạo cái danh mục
và mình cần mua nhá đầy Ví dụ mình cần
mua này để cậu sẽ hai chấm này sau đó
còn giữ an và các bạn bấm enter đấy ví
dụ mình lại nhanh cần mua là diễn gạo
đoạn giữa ăn và bấm enter nhanh ví dụ
muối này đấy Các giữa và bấm enter ví dụ
như là gà đây đợi hạn thế nhá Đấy là cái
cách mà mình tạo một cái dòng mới trong
một ô tiếp theo là gì ạ Cái thứ bảy là
mình gộp ô cho nhiều hành cùng một lúc
tức là diện ví dụ 2 ô này mình muốn cục
lại với nhau đấy nếu mà thông thường các
bạn cứ Bôi đen hai cái ông này cạn bớt
này để bạn Bôi đen hai câu này các bạn
bớt lại thì nó rất là lâu đúng không đây
Mình sẽ lưu lại nhé Thì chắc nghiệp mình
muốn tất cả các dữ liệu này cứ hai ô
liền nhau này thì mình sẽ mất hết hạn
thì mình làm như thế nào đúng không Thì
đầu tiên bạn Bôi đen toàn bộ cái vùng dữ
liệu này đấy cậu sẽ vào cái thẻ hôm các
bạn
a centre tích của đây đấy các bạn sẽ
chọn cho mình là diện mượt acro đây này
đấy các bạn sẽ cho ra cảm thấy cho như
vậy tất cả Cái ô này đỡ với nhau để lúc
này rất là nhanh chóng nhé Tiếp theo là
cái thứ tám là mình giúp bỏ cái giá trị
không ra khỏi biểu đồ đầu tiên các bạn
sẽ bố đem cái nguồn dữ liệu này các bạn
vào thẻ Asus này thấy con sẽ chọn biểu
đồ Ví dụ mình chọn các biểu đồ hình này
đi Đấy bây giờ các bạn xem rượu ở đây
mình hướng dẫn nha các bạn sẽ kích chuột
vào một cái giá trị bất kỳ Ví dụ mình
thấy chuột và các giá trị này đi sau đó
rồi Còn nháy chuột phải các bạn sẽ
data-label đây này các bạn chọn S
data-label đấy Đây là cái giá trị của
nhà họ sẽ tích vào đây một cái giá trị
bất kìa đây này Còn nháy chuột phải các
bạn chọn nhạ format data lấy bổ này tiếp
theo là gì ạ Các bạn sẽ vào cái phần 5
bò nhé Cả năm xuống dưới rồi đây để gạo
sự tích của năm bờ
ở đây ở dưới cái phần format code đây
này xóa đi cậu sẽ thai bằng viện thằng
này đã đoạn Thăng này chấm phẩy - diện -
Thăng này chấm phẩy nói con sẽ gõ như
này các bạn bơm ép vào đây đấy còn thấy
chưa Như vậy các cái giá trị không ở đây
nó đã mất đi đã nhìn rất là đẹp rồi
không ạ Nó sẽ không còn mới giá trị
không nữa đấy bây giờ ví dụ mình undo
lại nhé để nhận thấy chứ những cái giá
trị không Nó hiện ở đây nó rất là xấu
đấy thì bây giờ bỏ ra chị không là các
bạn nào như vậy Xong lại nghỉ luôn đi để
nó mất giá trị không Này nhìn đẹp hơn
đúng ạ Tiếp theo là cái thứ 9 là gì định
dạng giờ nhá Thì lúc đấy là ngày tháng
rồi đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ định dạng
giờ thì ở đây á Mình có 1 số cái thời
gian gọi nên là kết quả lại đây ví dụ
các công ty mà tổng số giờ gọi trong
ngày này nhá Bây giờ mình sẽ Định dạng
lại thì đầu tiên nhá mình sẽ làm cái
bảng này trước đi Đấy bây giờ nếu như
khi phát như thế này thì nó sẽ trả về
các kết quả tương ứng bây giờ ví dụ các
bạn Bun được cái vùng dữ liệu của mình
này các bạn ấn kahchan một đã chọn sẽ
vào cái seatravel Các bạn chọn cá tầm ở
đây cái format đến các bạn gõ chữ H
không ấy thì nó sẽ lấy kết quả giờ không
biết bạn bấm ok đấy thì nó sẽ lấy ở đây
là 4 giờ thì ở đây là 25 giờ nhưng vào
các bạn hiểu bản chất nó là 24 giờ cộng
một chút là 24 giờ là một ngày rồi đúng
không Thì nó chỉ lấy cái số giờ dư ra là
lấy số 1 thôi đấy Ở đây cũng tương tự
như nó sẽ dư ra 16 giờ đấy Còn nếu như
các định dạng là hát này hay chấm mm là
nó sẽ biểu diễn dạng giờ phút đấy thì
như vậy cái cửa dưới là đây nó chưa thực
sự đúng lắm Bây giờ bạn muốn biểu diễn
đúng thì các bạn phải thêm cái chữ H ở
trong cái đóng vuông này thì Cái chữ H
nó hoặc vuông này nó khác gì cái chữ H
mà không đóng ngoặc vuông tức là nó sẽ +
tổng giờ lũy tiến ơi cái là nó sẽ không
quan tâm về ngày lại nếu như mà 25 giờ
thì nó vẫn là để 25 giờ nó không tách là
24 giờ một ngày và nó chỉ
à mà nó lấy toàn bộ tổng giờ ở đây đúng
không các bạn Bôi đen lại nhé các bạn sẽ
ấn kahchan một thấy mình rất thay cái
chữ h này bằng tiếng mình sẽ cho nó
trong cái ngõ vua lại đóng manga này lại
đấy bạn sẽ bấm ok để em thấy trên lúc
này là giờ đây nó sẽ tập lại rất là hay
như vậy nếu như cái giờ của mình mà lớn
hơn 24 giờ mà các muốn biểu diễn về đúng
bây giờ cũng giấy thì các bạn phải định
dạng cái chữ H trong đóng mở ngoặc vuông
nhé Okay tiếp theo là gì Cái chữ hai cái
chữ m này nó trong cái mở ngoặc vuông
đóng ngoặc vuông thì nó cũng tương tự
như cái chữ H trong mở ngoặc vuông đóng
ngoặc vuông thôi tư là nó sẽ + tổng số
phút lũy tiến đúng không ạ Vậy tức làm
gì ở đây là 4 giờ 20 phút 23 giây thì
tổng bằng tất cả bao nhiêu phút mình sẽ
Bôi đen toàn bộ cái cùng dữ liệu này các
bạn ấn căn trên một nhá ở cái phần các
tầm các bạn sẽ xóa đi còn cho trong cái
mà vuông ra là hai cái chữ m đấy các bạn
có vuông lại để bạn sẽ bấm ok thì như
vậy nó sẽ quy về cái số phút này rất là
hay ạ tự như vậy Ở đây là 25 giờ
Bye bye đây thì sẽ bằng tổng là 1520
phút thì tương tự cái dây cũng vậy nha
cạn xâm nhập vào đây thôi là xong Còn
cái tem r phút giây này thì nếu mà nó
không quá 1 ngày thì bạn lên để như thế
này còn nếu như nó quá 1 ngày thì các
nên để diện trong cái mỏ Gun đóng ngoặc
vuông như thế này nhé phang cái 11 nhát
là mình sẽ nhập một số lớn hơn 15 chữ số
thì có duy nhất trong Excel Đấy cái phần
dưới dạng số thì nó chỉ nhập được tối đa
là 15 chữ số và ví dụ nhập cho bạn xem
nhé 123456789 như vậy là có 9D đủ chín
giới đường bộ không là 10 11 12 13 14 15
như vậy Ở đây là có 15 chữ số đúng không
Nếu như các số tiếp theo sau đấy là 6789
các bạn thức enter đi thì nó sẽ cho về
không hết các bạn tích vào đây rồi tích
về dấu phẩy này bạn kéo rộng ra đấy gọi
thấy chứ như vậy là so với số 5 này nó
xem cho về không hết tại vì gì ạ Hãy Seo
Ấy nó thì xử lý được 15 số này thôi
một số lúc nãy mình nhập vào 6789 thì nó
sẽ cho về thành công hết đấy Bây giờ làm
sao để mình nhập được cái giấy số vừa
xong mà nó không bị chuyển được không
này thì mình làm như thế nào thì trước
khi bị ngập bị thì các bạn phải được
định dạng nó về dạng tích đấy cậu rất
thích một cái ô cá kìa đây mình sẽ bà
với thẻ hôm này các bạn sẽ vào Cái ô này
là number format này đã thích ở đây các
bạn làm xuống dưới bạn sẽ chậm tách cho
mình thì lúc này các bạn có thể nhập một
cái số mà lớn hơn 15 chữ số được bị 123
này các bạn Nhập giống vừa xong nhá Đấy
cảm thấy cho cái số này nó không bị
chuyển về thiện những cái số và sau với
số năm thứ hai đây này Nó sẽ không bị
chuyển về số 0 đấy bởi vì lúc này mình
đã định dạng nó là Tết rồi đấy là cái
cách mà mình muốn nhập một cái số 2 loại
khác là một dãy số mà lớn hơn 15 chữ số
nhá Đấy mình phải chuyển nó về cái tích
ở đây thì mình mới nhập được nhé Sang
tháng 11 là mình ẩn cái giá trị của ô đi
thì các bạn sẽ Bôi đen toàn bộ cái phần
dữ liệu
Ừ giờ anh Tăng chân một đấy sau đó gọi
sẽ vào cái cá tầm ở cái phần dưới cái
phần chai này các bạn gọi cho mình ba
cái chấm phẩy đấy nó sẽ bấm ok thì như
vậy toàn bộ cái phần dữ liệu đây nó bị
ẩn đi tiếp theo cái 12 là thì mình sẽ tô
màu có điều kiện nhá thì ở đây là danh
sách nhân viên này đây là kế hoạch như
là thực hiện và đây là tăng trưởng Thì
bây giờ mình muốn là diện nếu như bạn
nào mà tăng trưởng Dương ấy tức là cái
thực hiện lớn lên kế hoạch chị thì mình
rất cho màu xanh Còn bạn nào mà tăng
thêm âm tức là cách thực hiện món kế
hoạch thì mình sẽ cho màu đỏ lại tìm để
làm việc này mình làm như thế nào thì
đầu tiên các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ
liệu ở đây đấy ta sẽ ấn căng trên một
nhá Vậy em có các bước rồi các bạn sẽ
thích vào các tầng ở đây thì mình sẽ gõ
là dịp Dương thì bạn chú ý nhắc dưới cái
cần than này còn gọi cho mình nha nếu mà
lớn hơn không đúng không Thì là màu xanh
màu xanh là Blue Để bạn xem đóng ngoặc
vuông này lại đây con sẽ cách chả gọi rõ
đi xa
ạ bây giờ chấm phẩy này tiếp theo là
diện nếu như màu đỏ nhá thì bạn mở ngoặc
vuông A Gọi suggests that là màu đỏ nó
gọn đóng vung lại đấy các bạn tách ra Họ
sẽ trừ tăng đấy thì ở đây mình sẽ giải
thích cho các bạn Nga trước cách chấm
phẩy đầu tiên ý nghĩa là nó sẽ biểu diễn
số dương còn sau cái chấm phẩy thì nó sẽ
là biểu diễn siêu âm đấy thì nếu như ở
đây chỉ có một chấm phẩy thì nó là như
vậy còn cái Blue ở trong mở ngoặc vuông
nó và Vương này thì nó là biểu diễn màu
nhé Còn Varus này là màu đỏ bây giờ gọi
sẽ bấm ok Các bạn thấy chưa Như vậy là
những cái dương ở đây nó sẽ màu xanh và
âm là lây màu đỏ lấy ví dụ cái bạn này
thực hiện là được 4.000 đây nhá Đấy thì
lúc này tăng trưởng lại là Dương đó lại
chuyển sang màu xanh rất là hay mình
indue lại nhé cái màu của mình thì ngoài
cái chuyện là các bạn Gõ cái màu tên màu
này các bạn có thể chọn cái mã màu cốt
mình lại vừa đen lại nhá các bạn ăn cá
trên 1
ạ bây giờ cái Blue này toàn có thể thay
bằng cái màu về Ví dụ mình KL KL lúc đấy
mình cách ra mình là 32 thì là Dương Quá
Đây ba hay là cái màu xanh đậm này con
cá Atlat này Bây giờ mình sẽ thay bằng
việc l36 tách ra 36 đấy Bạn muốn ok đấy
Gọi thế cho Đây là màu vàng này nó hơi
mờ con sẽ không nhìn được rõ lắm đúng
không một vàng này mở web đây ví dụ mình
cho cái 37 gặp Bôi đen này lại gọi ấn
các chân một nhé Thì mình sẽ thay 36
bằng 37 đi lại gọi bằng Ok Đấy 37 thì
màu nó sẽ nổi hơn một tí nhé đấy là cầu
với phần màu OK ngoài cái phần tô màu
các bạn có thể tô màu theo điều kiện nhá
Bây giờ giả sử cái phần thực hiện nhá
những cái ông nào mà thực hiện nhỏ hơn
5.000 thì mình sẽ cho màu đỏ đúng không
ạ Đấy còn lớn hơn 5.000 thì mới giữ cho
một cái màu khác ví dụ như là lớn hơn
5.000 trong màu xanh đấy mình sẽ Bôi đen
cái phần thực hiện nhà thì các bạn ấn
các chân một này đấy các bạn sẽ vào các
tầng
thì mình sẽ xóa đi bây giờ ví dụ thì ạ
Đầu tiên nhá là ví dụ nhỏ 5.000 thì mình
màu đỏ đúng không Các sẽ ghi là diệt gọn
sẽ address các bạn đóng học vui này ạ
Các bạn đó mà vui thế nạ tới đoạn diện
chọn cách giai đoạn mở mà vung Tiếp Tiếp
theo là cái điều kiện đúng không Ví dụ
như là lọ nhỏ hơn 5.000 thì là ra rồi
đúng không còn đóng mà vô này lại như
vậy mình đã xong cái phần màu và cái
phần điều kiện bây giờ Khoảng Cách nha
cậu sẽ ghi là gì Thăng phẩy Thăng không
đấy tiếp theo gọn chấm phẩy nhà các bạn
xem ở mà vuông ra các bạn sẽ ghi là gì ạ
ví dụ tiếp theo mình dùng cái màu với
hạn nhé color đây ví dụ K5 đi đấy các
bạn xem đóng ngoặc vuông rồi lại còn
cách ra gọn mà vuông tiếp là gì nếu như
mà lớn hơn hoặc bằng 5.000 các bạn đóng
mà vui thế này đấy tiếp theo là mình cho
tô màu gì tiếp theo mình sẽ định dạng
nha Còn cách nhà gọi thang này phẩy tăng
không đấy
chị sẽ giải thích cho bạn nhá đầu tiên
là gì Hai cái màu hoa gốc này nó sẽ tô
màu đỏ cho những cái trường hợp mà nhỏ
hơn 5.000 Còn đây là cái định dạng nhá
Đây là định dạng hàng nghìn này phải đây
là định dạng hàng nghìn tức là ngăn cách
hàng nghìn đấy nhỉ cho nó rõ thì sau cái
chấm phẩy này là tên màu thì kl-5 ở đây
nha bạn xem này kl-5 đây cả lại năm là
cái màu xanh này đúng không Đấy đang làm
cho những cái ông mà lớn hơn hoặc bằng
năm nhìn lại mình sẽ bấm ok đấy lại thấy
chứ rất là đẹp luôn đấy như ông nào
doanh thu nhỏ 5.000 thì màu đỏ và lớn
hơn 5.000 thì là màu xanh đấy đấy là cái
cách mà mình định dạng theo màu sắc ok
đến với cuối cùng là gì các ký tự vạch
cái này cũng khá là hay đấy bây giờ nha
cạn chú ý ở đây mình gắn cái hướng dẫn
rồi nếu như bạn để cái hiện cái gạch
ngang này chỉ có bạn sẽ là gì sao thăng
gạch ngang đây mình sẽ làm cho các bạn
nhấn ví dụ cái chữ kí mình sẽ biểu diễn
như thế này nhé Còn thức thích là cái ô
chữ ký này can chương 1 các bạn vào các
tầng ở dưới lại con sẽ gõ cho mình
a a còn này Sao lại sau đó bạn thấy gạch
dưới ship - đã sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy cái
chữ ký lại còn thấy cho nó sẽ có cái
cảnh dưới này nếu như cái ô này dụng là
bao nhiêu ý thì cái cảnh dưới này nó
cũng rộng ra bấy nhiêu để nó xuống cuối
Cái ô này có đấy cậu thêm khá là hay ạ
tiếp theo là ngày tháng Ví dụ mình muốn
3.so với phần ngày tháng này thì gọi
tích vào ô ngày tháng con ấn cao chương
1 này các tầng ở đây mình sẽ cửa là thế
a còng đúng sao lúc nãy cái cảnh dưới
thì mình sẽ thay bằng dấu chấm nữa gọn
sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy là toàn bộ cái độ
rộng còn lại nó sẽ điền cái dấu chấm vào
đây lạnh Nếu kéo rộng ra cũng như vậy
nhé Để rất là hai ạ tiếp theo là chẳng
hạn như cái số trang trong trường hợp số
trang sách các bạn nó lại là ba chấm ở
trên cùng này cơ đấy thì các bạn nào nào
còn thích là cái ô trang này con tấn căn
chung một nhá các bạn vào các tầng thì ở
đây gọi lại gì ở các bạn hãy điền cái
sao trước này sao này chấm xong mới đến
a còng đấy bạn sẽ
Ừ thì như vậy cái ba chấm này nó sẽ
trước cái chữ trang này rất là hay là
còn kéo dài bao nhiêu cũng vậy Để chị Ok
như vậy là mình đã xong cái phần bài số
10 ở đây là định dạng xem nhé Bây giờ
mình sẽ vào cái câu hỏi về nhà cho bé
phần bài tập của định dạng theo đấy thì
ok Bây giờ giả sử mình có cái mã vùng là
như thế này nhá Bây giờ làm sao ấy để
cái mã vùng nó sẽ có định dạng là năm số
đấy nếu như mình nhập số 1 và đấy thì nó
sẽ mua tôm không à đợi cái bài tập về
nhà nó cơ bản như này thôi nhé Ok như
vậy là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày hôm
nay ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các
bạn nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật video
mới nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ để giúp
mọi người cùng học hãy xem nhé Xin chào
và hẹn gặp lại à
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]